for centuries  we've been fighting and keeping track of  different things that move in and out of  this world  the most dangerous ones we find a way to  contain this is one of the worst ever  mom can you hear me  had a man speak with my mother i am a  mother  my body is a cage  it's mom the thing that's got a hold of  her it's gotten  stronger  this family's unnatural behavior  i've never experienced anything like it  what happened to them it wasn't some  random family tragedy  their father was evil  and mother cursed him for discovering  the truth  there are other forces that play here  the demons are powerful people like not  all of mankind  we can't do this alone we put them  together now  the will we blow back  you come crawling back  looking for mommy's love  the last thing the world needs  is a hellstrom family reunion  my body